okay lebron james so usually we're used
to watching him in the finals right now
we're not but
do you see his entrance and his
appearance at game
five the other night when he was there
with maverick carter and adele and he
brought his own bottle of tequila in and
you know it's interesting can you guys
name a more polarizing figure
in sports history in sports history i
just don't think
there's ever polarizing at the time yeah
like
probably muhammad well i was going to
say i don't think you can count muhammad
ali because
in his peak i mean it was hard not to
like him as far as alex rodriguez for
his basketball
that's what i compare him to yeah but
a-rod was different too
because i'd say there was more people
that didn't like a-rod than like them
i think there's more people who don't
like lebron than like him i don't know
look
lebron does unbelievable work in ohio
and akron i think it's like
i promise foundation sends like all
these kids to colleges
why not it's unbelievable what he does
as a community so for me took care of
the queens too so i mean
whatever you know he but he didn't have
as good of a jump shot
no it's true what are you talking about
huh what gotti
got he took care of queens like whenever
i hear people take care of her hometown
i'm like yeah pablo escobar was great
for his
three blocks you know you can't you
can't buy
favor if you're a jerk you're a jerk
yeah anyway um
right but i mean lebron compared to
those guys that's a little listen that's
a little over the top
yeah sure sure it is and i'm being
hyperbolic
but also i got it you know being the
face in the nba
and running on to your son's high school
basketball court to
have a word with the uh the announcer
because you didn't like what he said
like bro
can this guy go seven minutes without
making everything about him
have you ever met a more narcissistic
person in your life have you ever even
yeah but when the world literally does
revolve around calls himself
and he means it but you when people
enable you it's easy to understand how
that happened i can understand how it
happens and i can be
genuinely happy he takes care of his
people and still think he's a jerk i
will say this
he has to come back even though he's old
he's gonna be 37 next year i think he's
got to come back
and be an elite player again i don't
think you can do this and be at the very
very tail end of your career where
you're irrelevant as an athlete
and as an nba player so i think it's
really important on the space jam right
so now it's
space jam too so does where do you land
on that does that make it he's more like
a caricature he's like he's like the the
pro
athlete that doesn't get it from like a
90s movie about a pro athlete who
doesn't get it like he
he's like he's the guy who doesn't get
it until whoopi goldberg becomes his
coach and is like hey you don't
everything doesn't have to be about you
and then he learns to pass to his
teammates like he didn't give himself
the nickname king james like we all had
friends who might
but he didn't turn it down he didn't
turn it down when someone gave it to him
right
yeah anyway i when when lebron at his
peak i remember when he
left miami to go back to the uh
cleveland cavaliers
and espn did a huge tribute to him
because it was you know
biggest story of the day in the week
they played the highlights of his career
up until that point up until about 2014.
we're we forget just how insanely yeah
and that and that version that version
of lebron
right up until he quit on his teammates
and walked off the court was i thought
immensely likable that version of lebron
seemed like a guy who cared about
community he wanted to do well he worked
with his teammates
something in miami you know maybe the
the the heat that he caught
you know and becoming the bad guy and
embracing that maybe
something changed yeah but you just got
to keep politics out of it i mean you
can
you can you know do great things for
your community but i think as soon as
you enter
politics as an athlete it's just you can
never recover look
the he he likes to say hi haters and
show the numbers right that's what he
did with uh with space jam came out
you know and it got lampooned because it
got not one
not two not three not four not five
not six not seven stars it got zero
stars
and he took his talents to rotten
tomatoes so this dude is out here
talking about high haters showing the
numbers well
what are the ratings each year nba
finals with him in it
year over year up or down well i mean
down the last few years okay it's his
league he's the face of it
the ratings are going down the haters
are going down the proof is in this this
is a good series this is a good nba
finals
the nba's in good hands we talked a lot
i mean this was such an entertaining nba
finals i mean it was so
good it was so fresh the games were
competitive new stars it was fun to see
here i'll just say it i'll be flat out
look lebron james had a choice to choose
america or chinese chose china
so i don't have to support the dude he
made his choice god bless him
go be the king of beijing i don't need
them i don't want them i hope you
enjoyed that short clip from episode 2
of sports now with tom zenner there's
more where that came from here's another
short clip for you to click on from
episode 2
or episode 2 in its entirety right here
and don't forget to subscribe
to valuetainment sports